Speaker 1: So I've already played for you
a clip of Herschel Walker yesterday, not
very convincingly denying a second allegation of
him, urging a woman to get and ultimately paying
for her abortion. You saw Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham just laughing in the background,
laughing off the entire thing. Lindsey Graham saw
this as a great opportunity to go on Fox News and
to do his angry routine. This is the same routine
he did during the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation
hearings where he framed Brett Kavanaugh as the
biggest victim, maybe not only in the history
of the United States, but maybe the history of
the world screaming and just acting completely
ridiculous. He is now doing the exact same thing.
He appeared alongside Herschel Walker last night
on Fox News and he says the reason this is all
happening is because everybody is scared to
death about what a black Republican senator might
mean to other black kids. And there may be more
Republicans. And it's just scary to Democrats.
Speaker 3: But they're scared to death of
Herschel Walker, because if Herschel Walker
becomes a Republican, maybe every other young
child in America of color might want to be
a Republican. That's what they're trying
to do. Don't let them get away with it.
Team Herschel Walker. I want the biggest
night for Herschel Walker campaign to be tonight.
Speaker 1: Right. This is a character that Lindsey
has developed. I call it the faux indignation,
where he is just absolutely furious at grave
injustices that don't actually exist and that
are only meant to prop up bad candidates and
the lives of others. And that is exactly what
is happening here. Lindsey Graham is using this
to try to justify that Democrats
are the real racists. Democrats,
they only want black people in power if they are
on their side, when, of course, we actually know
it's the Republican Party that has this very
long history of only allowing very narrowly
defined black folks to be part of their movement.
Herschel Walker fits the bill. Take a look at more
of this lindsey graham insanity on fox news.
Speaker 3: I herschel they're beating all of
our guys up because what is it about this guy?
He changes the entire narrative of the left.
We're a party of racist, shawn. Man, you're a
racist. The Republican Party is racist. Well,
what happens when the Republican Party
licks and nominates Herschel Walker,
an African-American black Heisman
Trophy winner, right. Olympian. It
destroys the whole narrative. John James,
Tim Scott, Herschel Walker. Everybody in
San Francisco is going to jump off a bridge.
Speaker 1: Now, the reality is Herschel Walker
winning. First of all, Herschel Walker being
nominated changes nothing about the narrative
of the left. And Herschel Walker winning
would change nothing about the narrative
of the left. Republicans have for a long
time accepted and allowed very specific
minorities useful to them in very particular
ways to try to prove how not racist they are.
And in fact, they've done it with Herschel Walker,
where Herschel Walker has a platform that is
simply lies. He doesn't know what he's talking
about on any political issue. The big issue
for him was abortion, where it was absolutely
pro-life. Abortion is murder. No exceptions,
no exceptions, no exceptions. Turns out he now has
been accused of urging. Multiple women and paying
for multiple women to get such abortions.
And now when you criticize him and you go,
Walker has no clue what he's talking about. He's
a liar, he's dishonest and he's a hypocrite. They
come back and go, That's racist. You're that's
racist. You're being the racist because you're
saying this guy is a hypocrite and incompetent.
No, he's racist. I'm sorry. He's incompetent
and he is unqualified. And that's why we are
saying it. It has nothing to do with his race.
He hasn't actually said, by the way, even a single
thing he would do for black folks in Georgia,
nothing. He's not actually articulated a single
policy idea that he has to help black folks in
Georgia. And then and at this point, it's just
beyond belief. Lindsey Graham tries to interfere
in the Herschel Walker stuff by bringing up Hunter
Biden's laptop. Now, you might be saying, well,
that's important because Hunter Biden voters have
to decide, are they're going to are they going to
vote for Hunter Biden for the position of or
the position of. Oh, right. Hunter Biden's not
running for anything who say anything.
Speaker 4: But as I said earlier, they
messed with the wrong in Georgia. And right now.
Speaker 3: What? Can I say something? Well, that's
Hunter laptop and laptop. It was found to be
Russian disinformation right before the election.
It was true. It got suppressed right before the
election. You have an anonymous allegation from
a lawyer and le to try to affect the outcome in
a georgia race. They tried to destroy kavanaugh
because they warned the supreme court say they're
afraid of this man coming to the senate because he
would transform the Republican Party. We're
not going to let him get away with it. I'm
tired of it. I'm tired of seeing people I know.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay. He's furious. We got it.
Lindsey, by the way, the only transformation that
Herschel Walker would do of the Republican Party
is he would continue to prove that there is no low
there. There is no standard too low below which
Republican voters aren't willing to go as long as
it isn't a Democrat. You could be out there paying
for abortions and unable to explain your position
on any issue. But as long as you're not Raphael
Warnock with a D next to your name, there is no
standard below which these Republican voters won't
go. Absolutely stunning stuff. Make sure you're
following us on Facebook, Facebook.com slash David
Pakman show. We'll have all of these clips there
for your viewing horror, I guess I would say.